l'empoisonnement beaucoup plus grave que
l' affaire du sang contaminé puisque
c'est une population entière présent on
l'appelle le poison des antilles le
chlordécone un pesticide verser dans les
champs de bananes pendant une vingtaine
d'années un scandale sanitaire en
guadeloupe et en martinique et il a
fallu attendre 2018 pour que l'état
reconnaisse sa responsabilité
le chlordécone étaient répandues sur les
champs pour tuer les charançons des
petits insectes qui ravage l'est banani
dans les années 70 il est classé
cancérogène possible par l' oms
les etats unis ont donc décidé de
l'interdire en 1976
mais en france il a fallu attendre 1993
fini le chlordécone sauf qu'il persiste
dans les sols
nous savons qu'en ce moment il ya des de
stockage de molécules au niveau de nos
sols mais aussi n'ayant pas de labo
pouvoir mesurer les taux de résidus de
pesticides dans pas mal de produits nous
ne savons pas trop quelquefois export en
2000 le chlordécone est dans le viseur
des chercheurs il est relevé en très
grande quantité dans l'eau il est ingéré
par des espèces aquatiques
à tel point que la pêche est parfois
interdite par endroits et sur l'homme il
pourrait être à l'origine de cancers de
la prostate
en guadeloupe il ya un problème vraiment
particulier sur les tensions de la
prostate qui montre que nous avons trois
quatre fois plus de cancer de prostate
et par métro avec un groupe et qu' un
des facteurs elle finit sera
certainement dans l'intoxication pour
les pesticides dans cette archive de
2000 les spécialistes parlent de
pesticides de cocktail de pesticides
aucun produit en particulier jusqu'en
2007 avec une étude qui vise clairement
le chlordécone l'empoisonnement des
antilles et par les pesticides des
bananeraies se révèle beaucoup plus
grave que l'affairé du sang contaminé
les conséquences sont très graves le
taux de cancer de la prostate se situe
au deuxième rang mondial
sans compter les malformations
congénitales et les troubles de la
reproduction
cette annonce fait l'effet d'une bombe
mais l'état préfère attendre des études
complémentaires
depuis pas de nouvelles du scandale du
chlordécone jusqu'en 2018
l'état reconnaît avoir permis l'usagé
d'un produit dangereux peut être le
début d'une réparation du préjudice subi
aux antilles
[Musique]